[Music]
this all-star collab kicked off one of
the year's biggest nights in country
music carrie underwood and john
legend and e.t is breaking down all the
highlights from the 2021
cmt music awards
[Music]
lady a carly pierce and lindsay l opened
the show with their new hit
like a lady broken foot and i broke it
pretty good
and lindsay didn't let a broken foot
stop her from getting on stage
telling e.t before the show about the
daring story behind her injury
so i was chasing after my dog she got
out of the bus somebody left the bus
door open and she just went
plummeting out of it and so naturally
any dog owner
you run after them and i was in my socks
and i jumped from like the top step of
the bus
onto the parking lot and just landed
wrong
so it's you know i'm just gonna have to
get used to this
[Music]
another collab we can get behind mickey
guyton and gladys knight's duet of
friendship trains
the friendship train and the r b icon
had nothing but praise for the country
star
leading up to the performance how proud
of her
are you i'm exceptionally proud and for
you to be saying that to me
i cannot cry off my eyelashes right now
and all of this work my makeup artist
did kelsey ballerini and kane brown
co-hosted the ceremony
and kane joked with e.t about having to
keep up with kelsey's many
wardrobe changes well you know me by
myself
i would just have one outfit but this is
just my outfit for the carpet and then
we have kelsey that's another host and i
think she's changing like four times so
i had to compete with that i have four
looks and it's all bright and summery
and happy and i feel like
this is excited to wear this well i can
walk i just feel like ross in that
friends episode like getting it on
it was a whole situation on top of
hosting the big night
both kelsey and kane didn't go home
empty-handed
this is my first thing award kelsey won
cmt performance of the year
while kane nabbed trophies for
collaborative video of the year
and mail video of the year the latter
for his hit song
worship you i don't know what i do
yeah i might have to worship you but the
night's biggest honor went to country
mainstay carrie underwood
her duet with john legend hallelujah won
them video of the year
legend thank you for sending me this
incredible song
and agreeing to sing with me on it and
making this incredible um
video which i'm so proud of and
congratulations on what i think is your
first cmt award
leading up to her big win carrie
underwood told et
how she felt about achieving a cmt
milestone
you carry are the most awarded artists
in cmt
history with 22 wins
just a mere 22. congrats on that front
but what does it mean to you especially
since it's coming from
the fans i mean that is i feel like the
the best part of
of these awards is that people i mean
i've i was voted into this whole
life you know being being on american
idol and
um for people to still put that much uh
time and effort into voting and um i
mean they they work really hard
so it's uh i see i see like twitter
parties and stuff like that people
get on and they're like let's let's vote
you know at this time let's get together
and do it and i think that's so cool
you